hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in the course of his analyses of the
human emotions in rhetoric book 2
aristotle is typically going to pair
emotions off against each other so for
example
love and hate
fear and confidence and so on the very
first emotion that he begins with in
that rhetoric section is anger
and it's going to be paired off with
some sort of opposite or correlative
which is going to have several different
names in english we often translate it
as
mildness or
calmness
in greek proud taste is one of the terms
that aristotle uses which we'll talk
about in just a moment
he uses the verb proudness thai and he
also uses another noun which is related
to that prawn sis and so all of these
denote a
opposite or you could even say privation
of anger and he's going to treat this as
itself being an emotion now we do want
to be a little bit careful here to
distinguish particularly when it comes
to prague days between that understood
as an emotion as something that we feel
and the
virtuous disposition that is discussed
in the nick of mccain and eudaimian
ethics with respect to anger where we
may feel anger we can get angry at the
right time with the right people for the
right reason to the right amount in the
right way and so on which by the way
aristotle says it's quite difficult to
do
and also sometimes to determine
that's not exactly the same thing as the
emotion that is being discussed here
because the emotion is the opposite of
anger whereas the virtuous disposition
has to do with what we do with our
feelings of anger when we actually feel
them and aristotle is going to give us
somewhat of a definition here the greek
word is esto
let something be something else which is
as close as we're going to get to
defining something i suppose and so he
begins by saying
since becoming angry is the opposite of
becoming mild an anger of mildness he
says let's go on and define
what it is let's define making mild
you know causing somebody to feel
mild or to feel a
lack of anger
as what as the quieting and appeasing of
anger
so
quieting
catastasis quieting works it could also
refer to
a holding back you know a restraining of
anger that in some way reduces it or
perhaps even uh represses it uh you know
we could read a lot into this word
the other term um
you know amoresis is coming from amaros
and uh it has to do with peace
with introducing peacefulness
where there was rancor and ire and anger
before so he's using two different
terms here to convey i would say a
spectrum
of responses now this is a bit different
than the other emotions though love and
hate consider them right love is on one
end of a spectrum
hate is on another end of a spectrum you
could be neutral to somebody in the
middle you don't love them you don't
hate them you don't feel anything about
them
this is a bit different we have anger on
one side we have calmness or mildness on
the other side
but
calmness or mildness is really being
defined as not just the opposite but the
lack or privation or the
properly dealing with anger right
and aristotle says that we can actually
learn an awful lot
about we can determine scoping we can
literally look at or investigate
what makes for mildness now notice here
he's not talking just about the emotion
he's saying the things that make a smile
right so that's a a set of things that's
in the plural we can learn about the
things that make for mildness
from
opposites actual enantiome so if we look
at
key aspects of anger what makes people
angry how they get angry
and we think about the opposite to those
then we can understand what makes for
mildness and we're not going to go into
great detail
here because we're mostly interested in
the definition but i think
that looking at some of these opposites
can help us flesh out that definition
and wrap our heads around it a little
bit more so the first thing he talks
about is the sliding remember that
sliding
oligoria is absolutely central to anger
from aristotle's perspective that is the
cause the perception of somebody sliding
you is the cause
for getting angry so what happens
if there is sliding taking place
but somebody winds up being mild instead
it's in part because they
they realize some important aspects of
what's going on like he says
if men are angry with those who slight
them and the slight is voluntary
something that they they do
deliberately or by choice it is evident
that they're mild towards those who
don't do those things or who do them
involuntarily
or at least appear to be such
and towards those who intended the
opposite of what they've done and all
who behave in the same way towards
themselves so if
if there's a slight taking place
but you can say oh well they didn't mean
to do it they actually were intending to
do the opposite you know they were
trying to bring me a nice cake and then
they tripped and fell and the cake went
into my face they obviously didn't mean
it then then you stay mild you feel
mild towards them he would say
social status and humbling there's a
term that aristotle uses
several times here tus
tapeno menus right and this is uh coming
from a word to
humble to lower yourself to you know not
make a big deal of yourself in relation
to another person
and so
you know if you screw up but you you you
know say you're sorry and you admit
you're wrong and you
you know maybe even ask for forgiveness
he says that
people become calm towards them he's got
an example of the behavior of dogs
proves that anger ceases towards those
who humble themselves they do not bite
those who sit down isn't that a
interesting visual metaphor there
another
key thing is
seriousness
uh being spudayos being serious taking
things seriously versus showing contempt
cataphronesis
towards other people cataphronesis or
contempt is one of the three main modes
of sliding
it's when you show somebody else that
you think or you're literally looking
down or thinking down at them
you don't consider them particularly
valuable or the things that they care
about valuable and that makes people
angry on the other hand if you
display a kind of seriousness or concern
towards those people about the things
that they care about
then they will exhibit calmness towards
you they'll feel calm towards you right
a great example of this would be like
table settings i mean
i don't care about table settings some
people do
and if i'm having them over
for a nice dinner then i put the table
settings out because i want to show my
guests that i respect them and and you
know care about how they feel i don't
throw things down willy-nilly which
would be a sign of contempt right or
using dirty tableware right
another example
some of these have to do with emotions
fear
or respect
when we fear people
really fear them not just mildly fear
them aristotle thinks that we are likely
to be calm towards them even if they
they do slight us or if we respect or
literally feel shame uh towards those
people feel feel a sense of like being
um
how do we put it you know being on our
best behavior in relation to them we
want them to see us in a good light well
then we're more likely to remain calm as
well
those who we feel pity or compassion
towards we are likely to
exhibit calmness towards them rather
than anger pity could actually be a
substitute for the anger that we would
normally feel and that can actually be
quite helpful when people are doing
stupid things that otherwise might you
know be offensive to us because oh that
poor bastard he doesn't really know what
he's doing
he can't help himself and then finally
a very interesting aspect
aristotle says that when we are being
treated justly or
appropriately and he uses the term
decaya for
justice right and he also uses another
term that he had
used earlier
um
which has to do with here it is
okay so that long greek phrase means
you know they they don't think
that they are suffering something
against what is appropriate or befitting
to prosecute
and so if we
you know if things are happening to us
and we're like well i kind of deserve
that
or this is not
um
out of accordance with how things ought
to work for example when you're in the
army and a drill sergeant is yelling at
you in basic training
that's the way it's supposed to be
sometimes it takes you a while to figure
that out you get mad at them at first
but then after a while you don't because
you realize that that's the case or you
hire a personal trainer who is going to
yell at you and try to you know provoke
you into lifting the weights better or
something okay you're not going to get
angry at them unless you think that what
they're doing is wrong in some way if
you think that what they're doing is
appropriate or just then you remain calm
so all of these are you could say
dynamics that figure into this so why
bring all these up well aristotle
himself said if we want to understand
what mildness or calmness is we have to
look at the opposites so by doing so we
get a better sense
of what this
opposite of anger
actually looks like
you